[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine rugby et dans le
championnat de fédérale 3 versailles
remporte le derby contre l'entente
maisons laffitte saint germain les
poissy reportage à suivre course à pied
portrait de cyril picard dans cette
émission cet héninois participera ce
dimanche 17 octobre au marathon de paris
ce sportif ils sont six au club
d'athlétisme d'aubergenville espère y
réaliser une performance zoom dans ce
magazine en bas nous avons posé notre
caméra dans le complexe sportif pierre
de coubertin de monti le bretonneux pour
rencontrer l'équipe de handball de la
ville focus notamment sur la section
féminine qui évolue en nationale 2
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tb 78
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va parler un football la france a
remporté à la ligue des nations ce
dimanche soir face à l'espagne le score
2 buts à 1 c'est le genre du paris
saint-germain killian mba paix qui a
marqué le but de la victoire la limite
du hors jeu en plus de la star
parisienne catry vinoir remporte la
compétition presnell qui pembe est formé
au psg tout comme moussa diaby
aujourd'hui joueur de leverkusen et mick
mike maignan gardien du milan ac il ya
également matteo guendouzi joueur de
l'olympique de marseille originaire de
poissy la france remettra son titre en
jeu en juin prochain avec quatre matches
au programme en rugby à 7 et à le match
à ne pas manquer ce week end dans le
championnat de fédérale 3 le derby i
vinoy entre versailles et le mlsgp a
tourné en faveur dé versailles et après
un match d'une grande intensité le score
35 à 12 avantage de rémi lefebvre
[Applaudissements]
à
les supporteurs de versailles sont
repartis du stade de porchefontaine
combler ce dimanche 10 octobre leurs
protégés ont largement dominé leurs
voisins de l'entente maisons laffitte
sans jamais les poids si le derby noah a
été remportée sur le score de 35 à 12
aujourd'hui tout le monde a travaillé
ensemble pour l'équipe et ça fait
plaisir on a mieux 50 60 minutes à
débrider le match mais aujourd'hui les
ingrédients sont là y est ça fait
plaisir à gagner je suis très content
nous avons je pense qu'avec typhaine le
manager on est très content de la
victoire est là le comportement des
joueurs cet après midi
on avait vraiment envie d'avoir un match
référence un petit peu je montre un
petit peu l'état d'esprit du groupe et
on a pu voir aujourd'hui
contrat mais les gp vrai avec cette
victoire face à un concurrent direct
pour le haut du classement les
versailles et grimpe sur le podium de la
poule une de fédérale 3 avec un match en
moins ils reviennent à un point de leur
adversaire du jour les objectifs
entre nous des gens rester humble le
week-end par week end et qui s'est
accroché les phases finales et est monté
dans la division supérieure pour
continuer à rêver plus grands les
versets y affronteront et voit à
l'extérieur le 31 octobre prochain
[Applaudissements]
on va maintenant passer aux autres
résultats sportifs du week end dans les
yvelines bixente mérian santisteva nous
a rejoint sur ce plateau comme chaque
lundi on commence par du rugby et
plaisir qui jouer ce samedi en fédérale
2 sur une défaite 20 28 à la maison
contre le re plaisir ne comptabilise
qu'une seule victoire en quatre matches
dans une poule au niveau très élevé
alors notez qu'en fédérale 3 où il a
grappillé son premier point avec un
bonus défensif lors de sa défaite 14 à
13 contre evreux bixente on passe au
football avec versailles qui continue
son très bon début de saison en
nationale 2 exactement michael une
victoire 3 buts à 1 sur la pelouse de
romorantin pour le compte de la 9e
journée versailles est toujours la seule
équipe de la division à ne pas avoir
perdu le moindre match et se place en
deuxième position du classement avec 4
victoires 5 nuls et 0 défaite voici
l'autre pensionnaire yvelinois de la
division réalise un début de saison plus
compliquée une défaite 2-1 à la maison
face à l'équipe b de lorient qui laisse
les pisciacais en milieu de tableau 10e
avec 2 victoires 5 nuls et 2 défaites en
nationale 3 présent la 5e journée
l'équipe 2 du paris saint germain l'a
emporté lors du derby face aux mureaux
une victoire 2 0 qui place les parisiens
sur la dernier sur la première marche du
podium les mureaux sont 8e à la 12e
place le manteau fc qui a été défait 6-2
face au racing club de france à la
maison on descend maintenant de deux
divisions en régionale 2 avec la 3e
journée dans la poule b les deux
yvelinois se porte bien dans ce début de
saison où ils l'emportent 2-0 contre le
cosmo taverny quant à neauphle victoire
3-1 a uni les deux équipes se classent
respectivement deuxième et troisième de
là houle en poule d à présent poissy
venu à bout de trappes 3 buts à 1 un
succès qui place les pisciacais en tête
du classement tandis que trappe et
dernier la régionale 3 à présent bixente
on commence par la poule à oui une
victoire demain pas demain contre
villeparisis et un score fleuve 7,1 pour
versailles 2 contre les ulis co2 nos
repas est premier avec trois victoires
en trois matches versailles b et 6e dans
la poule c est un derby entre les murs
aux deux aimante de lui une victoire
sans appel 3 1 du mantois qui prend la
deuxième place du championnat
fort de deux succès lors de ses deux
premiers matches hardricourt a cependant
été surprise sur la pelouse de rueil
malmaison défaite sur le score lourd de
7 à 0 enfin marly le roi a aussi perdu
3-2 à boussens ville on termine notre
page foot par la deuxième journée de
première division de district et il
faisait bon être à domicile ce week-end
bixente oui cinq matches cinq victoires
à la maison le chesnay 4-1 contre
sartrouville carrière raisonnons
l'emportent 3-2 3-0 par mois ou deux
bailly noisy 3-1 contre vallée 78 bûcher
loi c-32 comme gargenville et enfin
voisins de zéro face à bois d'arcy en
tête du classement un trio donc avec le
chesnay kayak lésions et bailly noisy
deux victoires en autant de rencontres
bixente on passe au basket oui michael a
pas un bon week-end pour le basket
yvelinois malheureusement national de
poissy a été défait sur le fil contre le
gravenchonnais 86 à 83 en cinq journées
2 victoires et 3 défaites pour une clé
pisciacais 8e au classement en nationale
3 maintenant l'entente le chesnay
versailles s'est incliné contre vineuil
89 à 97 dans la poule f le lcv n'a
toujours pas remporté le moindre match
en quatre journées dans la poule g et
rap et marly le roi se sont inclinés
défaite 58 à 80 pour les trappistes
contre levallois et 62 70 face à rueil
pour marnie la seule bonne nouvelle et
côté féminin en national quand même il y
en a quand même michael l'entente le
chesnay versailles l'a largement emporté
sur les terres de bihorel 75 à 48 avec
quatre victoires au compteur le fcv est
en tête de sa division aux côtés de
nantes et de saumur du handball
maintenant ça ne jouait pas du côté des
féminines de monty lebreux tenu par
contre des rencontres se sont déroulées
chez les garçons oui avec la 4e journée
d'un de nationale 3 et 2 victoires
d'abord samedi l'entente où il veut
innés carrière a surpassé le pays
d'auray 32 à 24 et puis dimanche plaisir
les clés à des faits à la maison
également le paris sg 30 à 23 le hsv
s'est poursuit sa course en tête de la
division tandis que plaisir les clés se
donne un peu d'air et recolle au tableau
à la 6e place avant par avant de parler
cyclisme un beau de volée peut-être oui
une défaite pour le club de conflans en
élite dans un match accroché trois sets
à 2 contre caudry des regrets peut-être
pour les conflanais qui menait pourtant
2 sets à un avant de s'écrouler dans le
tie-break perdu 15 à 7 prochain match le
samedi 23 octobre ils recevront le stade
athlétique spinalien pour le compte de
la 3e journée alors comme annoncé le
cyclisme et bixente vous nous faites un
bilan des championnats d'europe qui
avait lieu la semaine dernière à granges
en suisse oui le bilan d'abord michael
ces dix médailles sur les 22 disciplines
qui avait lieu au tice au vélodrome de
grenchen où grange justement du 5 au 9
octobre alors dix médailles dont deux en
or par benjamin thomas et valentine
fortin c'était mercredi dernier pour les
deux sportifs benjamin thomas vainqueur
de la course aux points hommes et
valentine fortin qui a remporté l la
course aux éliminations dame un coup
double réalisé par valentine fortin qui
nous a apporté une seconde médaille
c'était mardi en terminant deuxième du
scratch alors deux médailles ont été
ajoutés lors de la dernière journée du
rassemblement européen oui à
l'américaine la paire victoire berthod
et marion boras a terminé troisième une
deuxième médaille pour victoire berthod
après l'omnium et une deuxième aussi
pour marion borras deux dauphines de la
poursuite enfin en kerim masculin tome
de rachat décroché l'argent derrière le
hollandais jeffrey ou l'inde parmi les
autres médailles on pouvait retenir
notamment thomas bouddha en bronze pour
la course par élimination hommes et la
troisième place également de mathilde
gros à la vitesse féminine et c'était
l'une des images du week-end mathilde
gros quiconque aurait aussi ok ring a
chuté dans une tentative de dépassement
je vous rassure a priori d'après un
poste instagram qu'elle a publié le jour
même elle va bien on espère revoir
mathilde de gros en grande forme dans
les prochaines semaines merci à bixente
pour toutes ces précisions on vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine course à
pied c'est le retour du marathon de
paris après l'annulation de l'édition
2020 cause de la crise sanitaire
la course aux 42 km se déroulera ce
dimanche 17 octobre parmi les
participants cyrille le picard le
marathonien licencié au club
d'athlétisme d'aubergenville nicolas
dendrite allé le rencontrer lors de sa
préparation
c'est la dernière ligne droite pour
cyril cliquards les dernières foulées de
sa préparation avant le dimanche 17
octobre jour du marathon de paris 2021
pour cet athlète de 43 ans spécialisé
dans le marathon depuis 2015 c'est un
retour à la compétition après la crise
sanitaire ça nous laisse beaucoup de
doutes à nous qui prépareront le
marathon en fait c'est jamais évident
parce que les sensations peuvent être
bonne mais la blessure peut arriver à
tout moment donc jusqu'au jour j il n'y
a pas de certitudes pour se préparer
c'est pas sorcier cinq séances par
semaine le mardi et le jeudi ça se passe
au club deux séances de fractionné le
mercredi c'est un footing de
récupération avant de conclure la
semaine par deux grandes sorties le
samedi et le dimanche une semaine type c
environ 80 kilomètres sur cette prépa
marathons les plus grosses semaines je
suis monté à 100 km c'est dernière
participation remonte à 2019 avec le
marathon des alpes-maritimes et le
marathon de paris des performances en
dessous de 3 heures mon objectif pour ce
marathon de paris ça va être de réaliser
à nouveau
moins de trois heures
mais trois derniers marathons je les ai
réalisées en 2h59 j'aimerais bien
franchir à nouveau ce palier la vitesse
le jour j pour le marathon va essayer de
tourner aux alentours de quatre minutes
entre 4 minutes 12 et 4 minutes 15 ooo
km ce temps là lui permettra de se
qualifier aux championnats de france de
la catégorie master ram et une autre
ambition est déjà dans son esprit
décrocher une place dans le marathon des
jeux olympiques de paris en 2024
en cyclisme sur route la semaine
dernière le coût réel en d2 l'équipe dsm
nicolas roche annoncé la fin de sa
carrière sportive à l'âge de 37 ans
après avoir notamment remporté deux
étapes du tour d'espagne en 2013 et 2015
le sportif a grandi dans les yvelines
dans la ville de conflans sainte
honorine jusqu'à ses 12 ans il était
d'ailleurs revenu dans sa commune de
coeur en 2016 à l'occasion du paris nice
il avait accordé cette interview juste
avant le départ depuis cinq six ans à
chaque fois ça se rapprochait on n'était
pas très loin de saint germain en laye
on était juste derrière et jc bon il y
avait un moment où on va tomber pile
dessus donc si c'était qu'une question
de patience et de temps mais
c'est bien que ça a été fait au moment
où j'ai encore quoi on va maintenant
parler à tennis en pleine préparation
pour viser une médaille aux jeux
paralympiques de paris en 2024 la
tenniswoman handisport pauline déroulède
a inauguré mardi dernier un court de
tennis à son nom dans les yvelines au
domaine de la corniche à rolleboise un
lieu symbolique pour les sportifs qui
s'entraînent à feucherolles l'hôtel
restaurant est un lieu où elle avait
l'habitude de venir en famille c'est
l'un des premiers endroits qu'elle a
fréquenté après son accident en 2018 on
écoute pauline déroulé de micro de tv à
c'est la preuve qu'on baptise un court
de tennis à mon nom c'est ça me fait
très plaisir ça me touche énormément
parce que voilà c'est pour la symbolique
c'est plutôt sympa c'est une façon une
première façon de marquer le tennis
fauteuil le tennis mon sport depuis
toujours donc moi je suis honoré
vraiment on passe maintenant notre coup
de projecteur chaque semaine tv 60,18
vous propose un zoom sur un club sportif
des yvelines aujourd'hui nous avons posé
nos caméras du côté du gymnase pierre de
coubertin de montillot bretonneux pour
rencontrer le club de handball de la
ville regardez
[Musique]
nous sommes au complexe sportif pierre
de coubertin de montigny le bretonneux
aujourd'hui je vous propose de découvrir
le club de montigny le bretonneux
handball une structure créée il y à 40
ans
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur
l'histoire de montigny le bretonneux et
ses 40 ans d'existence christophe reding
est à mes côtés bonjour christophe
bonjour michael alors expliquez nous un
petit peu l'histoire de
montigny-le-bretonneux cette équipe de
handball ça a été créée il ya 40 ans le
disais précédemment pourquoi tout
simplement tout à fait l'once était d un
professeur de sport au fait qui au
départ s'est dit mais pourquoi pas dû en
ballon en fait à l'école et pourquoi pas
créer un club ça commence et il était
entre 30 et 50 et aujourd'hui on est
avant coville on était un peu plus de
malheureusement les deux dernières
années
on a perdu un petit peu un petit peu de
licenciés et c'est un peu notre objectif
de remonter après tout ça de recréer
tout ça donc voilà je suis très content
michael en tout cas de vous retrouver de
retrouver aussi bien les gymnases de
retrouver les joueurs les joueuses
retrouver en fait du monde retrouvez le
monde social c'est un peu l'idée pour un
associé pour une association pour un
point brillant en club l'histoire de ce
club ben on commence tous bords et puis
tout doucement on gravit les échelons on
arrivait en niveau départemental niveau
régional la région ile de france est une
belle région on a eu une percée
également dans les années 90 avec les
barjots qui ont montré là
comment dire la voie en fait aux
différents clubs différentes équipes de
hand ball et
en fait il y en a même un qui nous a
rejoint philippe médard au sein au sein
du club et depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années nous avons une équipe fine
équipe féminine donc on a on a plaisir
en tout cas aujourd'hui même si c'est un
club du hand pour tous c'est aussi de
souligner le développement du sport
féminin et de et du handball féminin
donc on a une équipe phare qui est
depuis plus de 20 ans en équipe
nationale donc on a fait deux passages
en nationale une c'est compliqué d'y
rester donc là aujourd'hui l'objectif du
club c'est d'y retourner d'y rester et
de se développer et pourquoi pas avec
nos instances en tout cas d'aller au
delà de créer un club professionnel en
tout cas sur 50 ans ni ville seydoux
vraie volonté et à mon team automne est
ce qu'on peut dire que le club de mon
team auto ne compte maintenant dans le
paysage handballistique français en
français je vais rester un petit peu
humble en tout cas dans les yvelines oui
c'est clair on fait partie des plus gros
club yvelinois
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines n'y a pas
de club professionnel on reste sur des
plus hauts niveaux sur un niveau
national dont que nous sont les filles
en fait on est accompagné par deux trois
autres clubs c'est pour ça qu'en fait il
ya vraiment cette volonté d'aller au
dessus concernant l'île de france ben en
40 ans avec plus de 20 ans en équipe
nationale pour profits oui ça compte au
niveau national en montre la ville de
montigny quand même sur sur les
différentes régions chaque année donc on
est présent maintenant il faut rester
humble on est con nationale 2 mais il ya
une vraie volonté de pouvoir poursuivre
[Musique]
parmi un petit peu des ambitions de
cette équipe des ambitions du club je
vais donner la parole donc à notre
capitaine donc virginie qui est là
depuis cinq saisons au sein du club qui
a vraiment cette volonté d'accompagner
les plus jeunes en fait dans ce dans cet
élan voilà alors virginie je me mets à
côté de vous virginie depuis combien de
temps vous êtes ici à mon team en touche
arrivé il ya cinq ans j'entame ma
cinquième saison cette année avec les
filles et
je suis arrivé en 2017 si mes souvenirs
sont exacts qu'est ce qui vous a attiré
pour venir dans ce club alors il y avait
le challenge dans un premier temps il ya
beaucoup de valeur que je avec
lesquelles je me retrouve et le projet
du club
les valeurs du club les bénévoles c'est
une petite famille et maintenant je suis
à côté de dinard a chanté
depuis combien de temps tu es au club
alors moi du coup ça fait trois ans que
je suis au club je suis arrivé suite à
une blessure et du coup bah c'est un
club où je connaissais déjà parce que ma
chance je viens d'un club du 92 donc
j'ai été amené à jouer contre de paris
92 ans eh bien c'est exactement j'ai été
formé là bas et du cousin comme je
connaissais déjà c'est vrai que ça a
toujours eu une réputation assez
familial et ça aussi pour ma motivation
est aussi été l'arrivée de brahim qu'en
tant que coach que je connaissais déjà
et qui ai du coup été mon coach à paris
92 alors tu viens de paris 92 c'est
quand même une grosse structure est ce
que toi tu cherches est peut-être le
côté familial tout simplement avec une
structure a plus sa taille humaine ouais
c'est vrai que ça change pas mal parce
que du coup j'étais en réserve donc ne
pas être l'équipe première ça change
beaucoup et du coup arriver ici intégrer
l'équipe première être un peu haute au
dessus au dessus d'eux des catégories
pouvoir aider les jeunes et c'est ça
change et là je crois que je vais aller
à côté des deux on va dire aux yvelinois
100% yvelinoise du club noémie a
enchanté nos imier alors toi tu es 100%
il y monte n c'est ça j'ai commencé ici
à montigny aux alentours de 14 ans il me
semble que ça fait six ans que je fais
du rang de maintenant j'ai commencé donc
comme je viens de le dire à montigny en
départementale pour ensuite pour ensuite
monter petit à petit région
arrivé en
en équipe seniors j'ai commencé avec
l'équipe de dons qu'ils étaient
qui était en régionale achetez poquelin
pour ensuite arriver avec l'équipe hymne
national ça te fait d'avoir ce maillot
de mon team retenu en équipe senior
maintenant j'en suis fier j'en suis fier
parce que ça montre que le travail paye
et voilà j'ai une 106 3 c'est ça juste à
côté de moi maintenant aminata bonjour
alors pareil même question tu fais
partie des yvelines toi aussi est ce que
c'est important pour toi d'endosser ce
maillot de mon team honte oui parce que
j'étais ici déjà en moins de dix-huit
donc je m'entraîne ici je voyais
l'équipe une s'entraîner je me disais oh
ah et donc là maintenant j'y suis pour
moi c'est un bon club c'est un club
assez familial bonne ambiance et je me
sens bien donc c'est important pour moi
de retrouver mes racines pourries
guillemets le club de mon team bretons
ne fait partie des meilleurs clubs de
nationale 2 dans sa poule les objectifs
sans forcément élevées cette saison est
ce que tu ressens un petit peu de
pression non
trois dans le top 5 donc pour l'instant
ça se passe bien et non j'espère qu'on
va continuer sur cette lancée et pas de
pression pas de pression à un président
pour cette équipe senior il y en a
toujours formé à côté aussi on est aussi
on est on est totalement honnête et
objectif on est obligé d'avoir un petit
peu de pression maintenant ça fait
partie aussi du sport de haut niveau il
faut vivre avec la pression la pression
nous aide aussi à avancer maintenant il
faut qu'elle soit positive si on a une
pression négative en aidant les chèques
par contre utiliser la pression tout
comme le stress si on est sur un stress
dépasser c'est pas bon mais si on sait
l'utiliser si on celle anticipée et là
je reviens sur la pression c'est tout
bon pour nous et pour réussir ses
objectifs qui sont assez élevés il faut
un entraîneur brahim sadi est justement
à côté new brain sadi
quels sont les objectifs du club aller
le plus haut possible cette année en
nationale 2 alors les objectifs du club
cette année donc
comme celle de l'année dernière et
d'avant-vente qu'ovide c'est de figurer
le plus haut pour cible par le plus haut
du tableau
c'est de gravier les top 5 et au fur et
à mesure c'est d'aller chercher cette
place la numéro une c'est la première
place donc qu'on cherche depuis deux ans
on a essayé de le faire il ya deux ans
de cela malheureusement n'a été stoppé à
la dernière minute avec le co vide en
mois de mars et là on recommence et on
refait la même chose la poule elle est
très très très dense tout le monde peut
battre tout le monde comme on l'a dit et
je pense que les premières journées
peuvent peuvent le prouver mais nous
nous on a on a nos arguments pour
justement figurer dans ce top 5 juste je
vous le souhaite après les filles on va
aller voir maintenant à les garçons
comment le disais précédemment il n'y a
pas que l'équipe féminine qui est
présenté ici à montillot bretonneux il
ya également une équipe masculine qui a
un très bon niveau laurent vous êtes le
vice-président du club vous êtes en
charge de cette section masculine est ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un petit
peu plus c'est cela même au web nous
avons un groupe un groupe senior d'à peu
près 50 50 unités avec trois équipes qui
jouent à des niveaux
assez différent l'équipe première joue
en honneur région
l'équipe réserve est en haut de tableau
sur la division départementale et
l'équipe 3 est plus bas dans la
hiérarchie départementale ou permet de à
tous de pouvoir trouver une équipe et de
quoi jouer au handball surmotive est ce
que vous sentez que l'équipe progresse
d'année en année cette équipe masculine
alors oui c'est une équipe qu'on essaye
de monter de niveau pour répondre les
aspirations de des notamment des jeunes
du club qui sont de plus en plus
performants et oui petit à petit on se
voit là ce renfort sont là on est en
train de rebâtir un groupe pour viser
effectivement une à terme une montée
dans les échelons supérieurs de la
région
alors je suis maintenant avec eux le
coach pierre olivier alors pierre
olivier est ce que il ya la possibilité
d'aller plus haut pour cette équipe
masculine je pense qu'on se fixe pas de
limites bien précises ça va être surtout
comme l'a dit laurent un groupe qui en
reconstruction est en construction
surtout donc
il faut que la mayonnaise prenne et ça
ça peut prendre un temps absolument
indéfinie j'espère on travaille pour ce
soit le plus rapidement possible pour
atteindre un jour on espère le plus
proche possible
l'excellence régionale quand on est
coach d'une équipe comme celle là
comment on fait pour que la mayonnaise
prenne justement
c'est pas facile nous on a un groupe
j'ai un groupe qui est constitué de
divers éléments
de 16 ans à plus de 40 ans donc il ya
l'intégration des jeunes à prendre en
compte il ya les anciens qui vont
apporter leur expérience qui sont un peu
plus loin sur le terrain qui est
compensé par les jeunes donc c'est tout
un ensemble de travail et dax de travail
justement à l'entraînement de répétition
de cohésion de solidarité
ala eddine est ce que cette cohésion
vous êtes joueur dans l'équipe parce que
vous la santé oui ça commence à prendre
forme en effet ce qu'on essaie de mettre
en place c'est la mise en avant du
groupe avant tout avant l'indivision ça
commence à prendre forme tant en défense
qu'en attaque encore beaucoup de choses
à travailler comme comme c'est le coach
et laurent c'est un groupe en
reconstruction on part de loin c'est que
le début de la saison on commence à
avoir des objectifs qui sont atteints à
l'entraînement on n'attend plus que 1
valoriser tout ça pendant le match on
voit les filles hein juste derrière nous
elles sont en nationale 2 est ce que ça
donne pas un petit peu envie à cette
structure masculine d'aller en nationale
2 nationale une peut-être un jour un
jour le chemin encore extrêmement long
nous on est plutôt focalisés sur notre
travail pour l'instant régional et est
si déjà on atteint le plus haut niveau
régional
qu'est qui nous tend les bras qui est
pas si loin que ça on le touche entre
guillemets du bout des doigts ça sera
déjà super bien
et on termine avec la mascotte du club
laurent cros cottigny pour tout le club
c'est comme ça que les enfants ont
décidé d'appeler la mascotte à l'époque
donc ça fait cinq ans que
je suis rentré dans cette mascotte pour
aller voir au départ c'était surtout
pour amuser les enfants et puis après
c'est pas au jeu et puis j'ai fait
toutes les équipes
même les seniors masculins et surtout en
suis je suis le plus possible les filles
en déplacement
même en bretagne partout pourquoi et
pourquoi le crocodile alors pourquoi le
crocodile alors il paraît que le
crocodile c'est une ancienne mascotte du
club après moi j'en sais pas plus ça
fait 40 ans que le club existe donc
peut-être que je sais pas donc ils ont
voulu ça on a trouvé ça bon bah ouais ça
vous va comme un gant ça va comme un
gant oui l'été il fait très chaud dedans
mais bon après c'est pas grave au
contraire mais
j'avais quand c'est pour amuser les
enfants n'ont pas y a pas de problème
quoi et vous n'êtes pas que la mascotte
du club vous est également l'un des
responsables de la section handisport
est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus alors oui j'ai de monsieur
boulet graffet à m'occuper des
handisports
macé
en plus à cette année on a recruté huit
nouveaux joueuses et joueurs dont trois
personnes avec un
handicap c'est la première année qu'on a
autant de joueurs et de joueuses donc on
tourne à un effectif presque d'une
quinzaine de joueurs ce qui est
assez bien et en plus on passe de bons
moments on a des bonnes personnes avec
nous qui nous on s'ennuie pas merci
beaucoup laurent en tout cas si vous
voulez en savoir un petit peu plus sur
le club de handball de montigny le
bretonneux rendez vous sur leur site
internet moi je vais continuer un petit
peu l'entraînement
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]